just first we talked about a little bit
downstairs but how did you get involved
with project angel gosh I remember it
was a friend of mine it was back in like
89 90
I mean so yes it's coming up for 30
years at 30 30 year anniversary but who
knew and so I'll be serving the 12th
millionth meal today which is quite
extraordinary how does how does that
feel to know that you will be marking a
milestone for them in serving the 12
million people I think it's such an
honor really I mean we've been involved
with feeding the homeless and so it's
another kind of thing that we're
passionate about every week for 13 years
from Villa Blanca so it's something that
about giving back to the community and
these people have just done it so well
because they're the lifeline to people
at home that you know have terminal
illnesses it starts off you know as kind
of working with people with AIDS and
it's just a wonderful organization and I
think to draw attention to it is you
know something that I can do and it kind
of relies on volunteers so it's very
important what what is that altruistic
spirit come from and we were talking
again I mean I my family my mother's
been serving the homeless my whole life
so it's what I saw growing up so I
always felt like it was part of a pool
to me but where did that come from I
think it came you know I'd be married
since I'm 21 and I just even though
we've worked very hard and nobody ever
gave us anything we felt very fortunate
and very kind of privileged and in
London we started kind of a life of
Lantry and altruism just getting
involved with things that you know we
were passionate about and also being I
used word celebrity loosely because you
know what am I kind of celebrity for
what I just know that for today's
conversation I think there comes a
certain responsibility with it and you
know in these days of negativity and
it's just something you know I'm about
being positive I've had a lot of
negativity in my life over the last year
and I really I'm trying to focus on the
good that people can do and and bring to
the world and working with my own
foundation you know with the dogs and
the 501c3 that we create it brings me a
lot of pleasure and I think people if
they get involved they will have a
feel-good factor
about what they've done today and that's
why I encourage people has this been
part of what's helped you heal because
you have had a tough year
yeah loser suicide was very very
difficult my only sibling I really
floundered with that and you know
sometimes you just can't deal especially
being a restaurateur out in the public
eye and being on television it was very
difficult and then I just lost my mother
yeah just a couple of weeks ago so her
funeral was last week so just came back
from England but you know that's life
and we all have to deal with loss in our
life and it's about kind of moving
forward and remembering the good times I
think but also I do think philanthropy
and really giving back is almost like a
kind of selfish thing because it makes
you feel good about yourself you know I
remember hearing you say that you
reached out for help when your brother
yes passed away yeah I found that
particularly interesting because we look
at you as this the stronger larger than
life
nothing unflappable woman oh my god it's
true that's how we see you on television
so to hear you be vulnerable and say I
had to get some help
well I just you know I've never really
taken antidepressants I've never been to
therapy but there comes a time you know
in your life I think where sometimes you
might just need a little help just to
kind of get over the bump in life so to
speak and and losing like a sibling to
suicide you know I'd been involved with
The Trevor Project the suicide
prevention I never thought that would
touch my life and so sometimes it's okay
to say you know what I'm having a tough
time and to see a grief counselor or it
was really helpful but I'm not somebody
that sits around
I'm very proactive and keep myself very
busy and I think that's a huge part of
moving forward I don't want to get into
the my new share of everything that
happened Housewife seasons no I'm not
gonna get in the minutia but I will say
if I'm being honest because I am a
viewer - I'm interviewing you today but
I watch it I'm a religious watcher of
the show it was a big surprise to me to
see you
Kawai it's something I thought I would
never see when wouldn't it's all sat
with you now do you still feel like that
was the right thing to do you have any
regret about that I regret it was the
best thing for me at that time you know
I felt that I wasn't doing well kind of
emotionally myself and I wasn't as
equipped and I mean I've sat at reunions
this would have been the third reunion
where the whole cast has been against me
I've dealt with that and sat there for
ten hours but this was just a different
year and I was opening a restaurant I
was opening in Vegas I was doing
Vanderpump rules I was trying to get
over the loss of my brother I was you
know I just floundered and they just all
kept coming at me and it just became too
much
is that what it was because you would
hear the ladies always say well she's
been in this situation before what's
different now
like what's well my life was different
and I think sometimes life defining
moments and especially when you lose
somebody like your only sibling maybe
you know changed everything for me
you know it's yeah it's priority shift
and you say this is this is like doesn't
even compare to what's really happening
with me so I'm not even Undine I think
so yeah I think it was just a shift and
you know at that time I needed support
and it wasn't there and I think that you
know I was busy I stretched in all
directions opening tomtom here opening
Vegas doing Vanderpump rules you know
and all those things and trying to deal
with myself you know emotionally kind of
trying to heal it just became very
difficult and I just said okay that's
enough at all not at all I regret what I
regret is the fact that my exit wasn't
as positive as some of the wonderful
moments I've had on the show but you
know it's sometimes it's just what life
throws at you I've heard Andy say the
doors always open for you to come back
would you
it's too soon to discuss that I got he's
just kind of closed the door so you know
granite rock rules is going gangbusters
and it's a wonderful show and I really
enjoy being an EP on that and and I love
all the kids you know watching them grow
up and seeing them and helping them with
their struggles and I just hope that I
can be too
you know what I needed when I was
struggling because we've seen Jax has
lost you know his father and we've seen
Lala and you know all these kind of
things that they go through and
sometimes they need that support and I
think you know in life we all screw up
we all make mistakes and it's how we
learn from it you know for sure I want
to be really clear about this because
there's a lot of negativity you know
about this whole housewife situation but
I've really had an amazing time Bravo
have been incredible to me and I don't
want to see them bash for anything
because you know it's it's given me
incredible platforms to do wonderful
things you know and I'm very thankful
for that I know you said you weren't
watching the season the only thing you
watched was that monumental argument
with you and Kyle so you didn't see part
one of the reunion no you know did you
hear about them kind of bestowing the
Queen Beverly Hills tag upon Kyle that
she is now the I guess real Queen I I
mean to me that seems like a little
ridiculous because I it shouldn't be a
queen it's an ensemble cast if the
audience choose who they want to name a
queen that that's fine yes but if
they're being honest you know that for
many years you were thought of as the
Queen I think it was the show was great
when Carl and I were great together but
she chose to change that and that was
fine
that's what still sticks with me Lisa if
I'm being honest with you I know you
guys went through something but the show
was at its peak when you and Kyle were
together having a great time
either going ever of change the cheeki
is never some of the most fun television
that we've seen that would never change
that but that's done and this isn't
[Music]